welcome back is las vegas a seller's
market how is the housing inventory here
with the answers is harvey blankfeld and
he is with las vegas real estate now who
are sponsoring this segment welcome to
the show harvey thanks for having me
back jason okay talk to you about it
housing inventory compared to activity
talk to me about it okay so when the
pandemic started the inventory is right
around six thousand i'm talking about
single family homes about six thousand
homes available in our market it started
to slip right at the beginning of the
pandemic and in this past uh march and
april was down to under 2 000 less than
2 000 homes available in their market
and then now we've gotten just over 3
000 homes recently uh you can see on the
chart that it was very very low now the
interesting thing about this chart is if
you look at the orange line that's the
activity that's how many single family
homes sold every month pretty consistent
right right in those three thousand but
you saw the inventory was high they went
really really low and now it's coming
back it's coming back is it back all the
way the answer to is it a seller's
market is yes it still is but not as
feverish as it was just a few months ago
how long do you think it's going to be a
seller's market well i think it's going
to be a while yeah i think the demand is
still going to be there and i think that
with that uh creates it creates the
activity you know the laws of supply and
demand dictate uh pricing and the demand
is going to be pretty consistent i think
now before we went on the air you and i
were talking about uh buyers waiving
appraisals are they still doing this
yeah you know one of the uh impacts of
the inventory issue was that buyers were
waiving appraisals entirely when they
were doing their financing they said to
the lender listen i don't care what an
appraiser is that i'm paying the price i
agree to so the seller will sell to me
now they're doing to a certain extent
but now they're capping it they're
saying hey i'll pay above the appraised
value up to ten thousand dollars okay
what i want to tell sellers is this as a
listing agent i would tell sellers if
they're gonna cap the top i want you to
put up a minimum on the bottom okay tell
the buyer listen that's okay that i'll
i'll let you put a cap on top but i want
there to be a minimum on the bottom as
well to protect me from this appraisal
coming in so low and that's not a hammer
transaction give me an example so house
is suddenly say a hundred thousand
dollars give me an example 100 000 the
buyer uh promises to pay over ten
thousand and it appraises at 85 000. so
the buyer's now committed to paying 95
for that home okay okay you're
protecting yourself and protecting
themselves so with the and what and what
the if it had come in at like 80 or 70
the seller wants to say to the buyer
listen if it comes in much much lower
than that 10 gap i want you to know that
you're committed to paying at least a
certain amount of money that's what i'm
suggesting you're so full of information
i love this someone's watching right now
and they're planning on buying a home
for the first time what's that one piece
of advice you'd give them you know meet
with a lender first and talk about your
financial picture get a good idea of
what you can afford go into the market
knowing what your monthly expense is
going to be how much money you have in
the bank so that when you write those
offers you know you're going to get that
home
that's the importance you are describing
when my wife and i were looking for a
house we just started looking at homes
let's do this let's do that and then we
went to the bank we're like oh
yeah let's dial it back a little bit as
a realtor i don't want you looking at
homes you can't afford i'd love to you
to buy something but i don't want you to
look home you can't afford it's just
going to be disappointing and i also
don't want you to get homes that are so
low in your spectrum that you're just
not happy with anything you see i want
you to fit into the right spectrum i
want you to find the homes that are just
right for you awesome harvey you're
amazing appreciate you joining us today
thank you las vegas real estate now for
sponsoring this segment for more
information call
702-203-1165 or find them online at lv
estate
rocky